[Music]
welcome to hannity this busy friday news
night and tonight we are tracking
multiple developing stories including a
ridiculous criminal indictment against
steve bannon because he won't
participate in the democrats january 6
political charade with a predetermined
outcome now coming up we actually have a
comprehensive list of democrats who also
need to be indicted for actual crimes
and tonight we'll also show you the
latest terrible horrific economic
numbers every family in america is
feeling it and another bizarre moment
from kamala harris in france plus a new
development from the durham probe and
later a full report on cartel violence
now raging inside the united states as
the crisis on our southern border moves
north as it spirals even further out of
control but first the trial of kyle
rittenhouse will soon be coming to an
end on monday we will hear closing
arguments and then the jury will be
headed to the deliberation today the
prosecution they asked the judge to
allow the jury now to consider several
lesser charges hmm i guess they figured
out what we all know and that is their
case is not going very well and now at
the 11th hour they are attempting to
lower the bar
maybe they overcharged in the beginning
now some of these requests have been
accepted others have not
several other charges are still under
consideration by the judge who once
again berated the prosecution and again
for good cause take a look
that's your best picture the one i saw
over there no
where's the best picture please
that we'll we'll show it to the finder
you're asking me to give an instruction
i want to see the best picture
uh
it's the
we need to get mr stewart over here i
think we need that you need it on the
big tvs
you need another big tv
from bizarre weird pointless arguments
weak evidence hypothetical questions
allegations one after another of
prosecutorial misconduct prosecution has
been a dumpster fire from beginning to
end now no matter what happens with the
charges the facts in this case they
remain the same based on video evidence
and there is a lot of it and eyewitness
accounts there was a lot of that as well
it is apparent that 17 year old kyle
rittenhouse was defending himself from
imminent bodily harm or even death in
other words exactly what the wisconsin
law allows for now the first individual
shot and killed a 36 year old man named
joseph rosenbaum rosenbaum was a
pedophile convicted of sexually abusing
five little boys ages 9 to 11. prior to
the riot in kenosha rosenbaum was in a
psychiatric hospital for attempting
suicide and according to rittenhouse and
other eyewitness accounts rosenbaum
charged written house assaulted him and
then attempted to grab his gun before
rittenhouse ultimately defended himself
and discharged his weapon now
rittenhouse was then chased by an angry
mob we've shown you this tape of rioters
who knocked him to the ground attempted
to literally curb stomp his head right
into the pavement now one of the
individuals chasing him was a 26 year
old named anthony huber now huber was
also a convicted felon who once held his
own grandmother and brother at knife
point he was ultimately charged with
false imprisonment and choking his
brother later he faced drug and
disorderly conduct charges on the night
of august the 25th uber assaulted
rittenhouse with a skateboard and then
attempted to grab his gun before written
out shot and killed him his life was in
imminent danger now shortly thereafter
the third individual who was shot but
survive
his name is gage grosskroyce he pointed
a loaded gun at rittenhouse's head he
admitted it on the stand under oath
pointed a loaded gun at his head before
rittenhouse shot him in the arm in
self-defense now this guy crosscoats was
a 26 year old college senior who was
previously convicted of a gun charge and
several other misdemeanors now despite
all the facts in this case the video
evidence the eyewitness accounts the mob
the media their friends and the
democratic party they're all eager to
vilify and have been from day one 18
year old kyle rittenhouse they all made
up their minds months ago before any
evidence was presented they rushed to
judgment they obviously don't believe in
due process they don't believe in the
presumption of innocence he was enemy
number one from day one watch this
what the wright is saying about kyle
rittenhouse is that well the government
didn't do its job so it took a 17 year
old kid to come in and do what was right
that's vigilantism that's not what
people are not supposed to be vigilantes
that acting job of the crying i can't
even look at it well this is
that is one of the worst acting jobs
i've ever seen he committed a murder or
two murders and attempted to murder
someone else what kind of idiot
17 year old gets a giant gun and goes to
a riot he has no license he has no
training he thinks he's going to scrub
graffiti off with his ar-15 i mean the
stupidity of this when ridden house got
emotional it may have come across the
jury as a genuine expression of remorse
or on the other hand
maybe it was crocodile tears designed to
elicit sympathy this is white privilege
on steroids
i loved uh jeffrey two but in particular
what kind of idiot lawyer would do what
he did
on a zoom call
anyway while the mob and the media and
of course politicians rushed to judgment
and they're vilifying kyle rittenhouse
they're also very angry at the judge
who's presiding over the case why oh
because the judge has been very tough
rightly so on the prosecution rightly
calling out their dirty tactics all
along the way he also wore oh god forbid
an american flag tie on veterans day and
his ringtone was a version of lee
greenwood's god bless the usa and he
made a joke about a supply chain crisis
so now the media mob are accusing the
judge of being a racist monster in other
words what they call anybody they
disagree with and auditioning for a job
on the fox news channel maybe we should
have a judge show who knows take a look
the judge's actions during the trial so
far now coming under scrutiny and
raising questions about his behavior and
demeanor let's talk about the judge
actually let's play this because i've
never seen anything like this before or
a judge yelled quite like this oh we
don't have it but you saw the judge
going bonkers this judge yelling at a
prosecutor or anyone in the courtroom or
treating anyone the way that he treats i
think it's problematic and i don't think
it's normal he is he has made a series
of decisions each one perhaps may be
individually defensible but in totality
lead to the impression of a biased
racist judge it appears that this judge
is auditioning for the cameras and
looking for his next gig on fox news or
or own or whatever oan or whatever it is
i mean this judge is going beyond the
pill
remember in the twisted world of the mob
in the media the democratic party
there's no presumption of innocence zero
due process and no rule of law just
feeling an opinion and by the way
they're usually wrong they were wrong on
ferguson they were wrong on baltimore
freddie gray or your many were wrong in
uva the duke lacrosse case richard
jewell um oh remember that kid from
covington high school yeah he's going to
be a billionaire and when their feelings
and opinions are derailed by facts and
logic well the left just screams racism
what a shock everything the left doesn't
like apparently is racist everything
every voter who doesn't vote the right
way well we'll call them a racist too
every two years every four years that's
their playbook every american that
doesn't agree with them every person
that dares get in their way if democrats
really cared about what really happened
uh in a riot why don't they pay
attention to the 534
violent rights that took place in the
summer of 2020. where is that commission
liz cheney uh maybe they should start a
commission just like they did with the
violent riot that we condemned on
january 6th they don't seem to care
about truth or justice or equal justice
or equal application of our laws or the
pain and suffering they only care about
the narrative remember in the summer of
2020 dozens of americans died thousands
of cops were injured billions in dollars
in theft and property damage and arson